what was it like whenever you guys went
over to Joe Rogan I know you're a huge
Joe Rogan fan me too
and I remember the first time walking
into like his lair it's like I feel like
for me I felt like I walked in a like
like where they wrote the Bible and like
what the Bible had like some crazy
different chapters like people were you
know people were [ __ ] arm wrestling
and before you know eating [ __ ]
albatross nuggets and just doing wow
[ __ ] you know yeah that's what was
y'all's experience like when you guys
went over there I was nervous as [ __ ] me
too I'm like cool in the night before I
got this Airbnb and I didn't look at it
I'm like oh yeah two miles from Rogen's
place I figure it'll be a nice little
place it's some ghetto ass apartment
audio studio one bedroom one bed and
it's like so Tim and I are [ __ ]
sleeping in that bed and I'm like under
the top covers he said it's a con
comfortable just greasy just increasing
the [ __ ] hahaha
pictures of the apartment or of like the
lady and her family that lived in there
and it was just [ __ ] awkward it
wasn't awkward it was and it was like
weird to be in there cuz it didn't feel
clean yeah
but and then we so we got caffeine up
and went into Rogen's and uh I was
[ __ ] nervous I'm like I know his
podcasts are long three hours these are
[ __ ] super smart I feel like half
[ __ ] half the time yeah especially
around you know my god but I felt like a
god it went good yet our - I feel
completely I feel like one of those
people that got molested in the
wheelchair
honestly brah no offense but like I feel
at our - I don't know how he keeps going
man yeah it's impressive and he never
has to get up and pee I I think I
remember if I got up and peed but I
remember having to pee but you always
just [ __ ] toughs it out
yeah I get afraid to pee him in there
like I was like yeah I was yeah I was
nervous like what do i do just drink it
like what do I do like what was supposed
to be yeah but what would you okay -
yeah Rogen's the [ __ ] man it's crazy
how how influential he is nowadays -
yeah sweet though like all the guests
you have on there you can have funny ass
[ __ ] on there a really really
smart [ __ ] down there or
high-level athletes and he can relate
with all of them and talk and have a
good conversation
smart smart [ __ ] it's sweet that
we are able to listen to him like that
oh yeah man yeah he's so curious it's
like um at a time it's funny at a time
where where people kind of hurry to make
choices and decisions and hurry through
everything it feels like he goes long
form and he's so curious like he
genuinely like wants to know yeah and I
think it helps the rest of us that you
know learned yeah for sure I've learned
a ton listening to his podcast for
though over the years yeah
even like like I know I don't know what
the [ __ ] I don't know about politics I
don't know what a Republican I don't
know whatever I don't know far I don't
five only politics I ever [ __ ] me
ever heard of his from you know Rogen's
yeah pretty interesting listening to
their perspectives on that yeah when he
had Bernie Sanders on I thought it was
real interesting cuz I didn't know
exactly like I mean you hear all these
like little clips online and stuff but
to get like a real idea of sitting down
and listening to somebody you get to
know them a little better you know for
sure I thought I was a lot more real
yeah for sure I think that's how most
those talk should go like the important
ones yeah long conversations like that
instead of like they say 30 seconds
commercial yeah crazy evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one